e tô contigo
[Música]
efe
não é mole
[Música]
e aí galera que aceite meu canal do povo
vocês mais um vídeo aqui no cativeiro
para dizer que eu estou ficando doido
certeza absoluta que fico pensando meu
deus sei quanto tempo vai demorar para
suportar a sair correndo na rua no dia
da campanha pessoa sabe eu fico pensando
besteira de mais caras ou não sei acho
que engrandece o time já no eu eu parei
e pensei comigo a gente saia
transparente quando bate na água fica
amarelo que é isso um universo as coisas
e pescaria ficando doido é uma coisa que
acontece muito com vocês já presta
atenção que às vezes a gente pára e
começa a olhar com um ponto fixo sem
pensar absolutamente nada
você fica para que a pessoa que está com
você realmente não entendi na boca após
ter o pedido foi bené exame vão ter que
aparecer num não é pensando é ter a
viagem atenção porque está a pensar nada
nada simplesmente estava olhando você
fala que a pessoa está pensando na
verdade estava assim ó
nesta era o cérebro da gente viajando da
ganassi é coisa que acontece hoje 8 o
treinador eu dei meu deus vou dar meu
corpo quando eu não tenho tempo a dormir
meu corpo que é dormir à porta pegar
você joga amanhã minha alma fica na cama
levantando mantém plantão na agora diria
que é feriado que eu tenho muito tempo a
dormir do nada meu olho abri meu cérebro
como é senhoras e senhores indicar às 6
horas da manhã com o tempo a dormir e 10
pontos
vamos acordar o goleiro é com os 25
tanques 2006 é hoje ou já antiga mente é
outra preocupação que eu tenho de mais
para 15 anos atrás era tudo isso tinha
oito anos para 15 anos atrás da
preocupação 15 anos atrás era se és a
igai pelo meu nariz para tomar
refrigerante era um reino que a criança
não dá o tempo do gás acostumado copab
do duto de gás expõe o o lixe de lágrima
lagoa desse eu falava e também só tu
quer saber o que tinha onde também
quando era criança eu não sei se vocês
também sentia isso mas eu tinha ódio de
cortar a unha e como sente uma gastura
tão grande que eu cortava as unhas e eu
não consegui pegar em mim cara eu
cortava o nome da criança passar o dia
todo e assim aquela gasto no meu corpo
assim o é do acontecia isso comigo passa
o dia todo e assim vamos pra cima e quer
encostar na véspera não me crescer era
tudo diferente durante oito anos até
2008 ano hoje nossas televisões mais o
diário que não gostou muito de novelas
dele a televisão ter avançado já em
tomar os seus hubs problema nem perto da
televisão chico doido quando tinha 8 na
minha diversão era quando alguém
delegado edson eu corria papel da
televisão para encostar no braço nos
cabelos subir praga na televisão chegava
perto os cabelos subir a pregar o cabelo
vez instalado jogar pedra televisão
fazer tapa na bola parada que levaria a
taxa que esta revisão de quando eu tinha
8 anos pra cá mudar não tem mar botão de
volume de ligar de mudar tudo pelo
celular mas deixam controle pelo meu
smartphone a 15 na televisão um tubo
gigante há algum botão às vezes caía se
mudava com dedos em mudar o inter aqui
acho que a única que tinha o perfil
físico apresentado por aqui eu quero
falar de ninguém nem mesmo essa peça
pregada na tradição do show hoje a
televisão gigante a fim não tem botão
seu próprio negócio não dá para ligar
não existe é da [__] vai espantar o cão
de escravo é tudo assim somar não no fim
nossa senhora o céu num cativeiro desde
aqui um susto desse televisão evolui
agora uma coisa que não evoluiu na
televisão se chama volume desde 15 anos
atrás é a mesma coisa para amanhã
domingo de madrugada assistindo na
televisão para o volume deixa 10 o pai
nessa pessoa vota num seu voto não fica
assim
estou assistindo ali o dólar parou e
pensa assim um valor nunca muito baixo
por votar no 27 bota no 2 a 1 dentro do
buraco no botão de mudar vou fazer é
apertar e direta o show da fé meu amigo
mínimo você é você mesmo está na frente
liedson ea mãe apareceu 41 é dizer a
assistir no culto o pastor é muito
gostoso de assistir rolador não tinha
como esconder e agora foi que mudou
muito pra mim 15 anos atrás e e hoje é
cãibra hoje eu aceito antigamente quando
eu tinha 8 ano campo pra mim era coisa
pior que existia na terra tá na escola
eu olhava que o chile não votava kyoto
mil por cima do braço quando eu acordava
o braço estava dobrada de outra pessoa
pensava umidade não não acredito vai
acontecer aquilo até o momento a câmera
que você não pode se mexer com você se
mexe dói ficar com nossa aqui ai ai eu
mexo de pilão e quando está com cama
sempre o mp para fazer isso aqui o meu
né na mão é na rua
fica quietinho de novo mandou hoje
quando eu tô com o campeão mesmo a cabo
cunha não estou sentindo kleber dizendo
num passa-passa passará a raça pô passou
pronto dos animais ascobom antena
parabólica nunca mais vi eu tinha medo
antena parabólica que tinha abelha
sempre a marcar bem achava que fazer com
merda em cima do negócio da antena
parabólica e falar vai mexer até na unha
com um cabo de vassoura
eu batia também a mãe tinha medo de
queimar até para botar um balde e coisas
mudam cara novela eram totalmente entre
os índios nasce uma nova que a abertura
da novela não são atrativos igualmente a
abertura da novela as coisas mais
estranhas renato roque santeiro é um
fusca saiu de dentro do flor entendeu
muita coisa mudou e é um cara aí uma
pesquisa esse dia das 10 pessoas mais
assistido da história está grande e eu
tô na 10 antonio a 10 anos outras
pessoas eu tô entre a idéia é o segundo
mais assistido de histórias do mundo é o
carlos makhachkala e penedo em alagoas
eu sou o sexto mais assistido do mundo
estágio é o sexto de todo seu tempo é
ótimo eu me sentia da ex atleta de
olimpíadas que cheguem seja ficar
exploded felício chegassem ser peça e
chegou em sexto e direito de todos
eu sou seja para todas as pessoas do
mundo nadando ao mesmo tempo no verão
chega sexta esse crescimento deve ser
muito difícil as pessoas que torcem pelo
meu mal e veio crescendo de honra saber
que esse é um pano de tudo tem que ter
um plano de vida quando eu saí de casa
eu tinha um plano falei mãe eu vou eu
vou voltar rico você vai ver eu tinha um
plano de vida meu pai teve um plano de
vida e minha mulher tem um plano de
trabalho trabalho trabalho trabalho é um
10 anos a quem sabe daqui uns 10 anos
tem um filho é que saiu a notícia e
luiza não diz não vai ter fim assim que
saiu a notícia luiza diz que não vai ter
filho lucca não vai mas na verdade é um
plano de vida nossa não quero que meu
filho tem a vida que eu tive quando era
criança meu pai só trabalhava às vezes
nenhuma vez por semana meu pai pegou
meus primeiros passos na sorte ele
estava em casa um pouquinho um tempinho
levantei falei vou ganhar essa foi
esperar ele chega ele vê ele viu na
sorte meu pai trabalhava muito caro às
vezes chegava em casa na escola e
tentava sair não vai viajar tanto que a
primeira palavra que eu disse foi já vai
criança todo mundo vai falar ele vai
falar de chá vai
chega a raiar gente o que é isso a gente
que tá ali junto a gente cair no dia dos
pais querem o dia das mães cair nas
festas juninas cair na apresentação
teatral que na primeira apresentação de
não sei o que lá quer pegar o desenho
que a filha deve olhar e falar no meu
deus do céu que lindo esse elefante
dessa cor que não tem elefante verde mas
está lendo a linguagem seja ideológico
adotado vai ter o maior amor do mundo
porque sim eu tenho vontade de ter um
filho claro que a gente tem muito
integrada também tem vontade de ter
filho mas a gente já viajou muito o
mundo tem muita criança no mundo precisa
de família por isso é importante se você
tem um plano na sua vida entendeu meu
pai tinha quatro filhos para criar e uma
com um problema no coração tinha que
trabalhar em bonn condenado como se
fosse hoje quando meu pai montou um
plano de vida gente tava lascado meio
mais rapidamente esforço de onde a gente
morava todo mundo perdeu o emprego o pai
falou vou pegar o dinheiro emprestado
vou comprar uma moto vou tirar todo
mundo dessa miséria que a gente tá
vivendo assim ele fez passou no banco
fez um empréstimo foi na onda perguntou
quanto era comprar uma honda xlr era uma
sensacional ea gente sofreu interior e
de remédio para conseguir as coisas
botar do jeito que está hoje e logo a
minha mãe fez um consócio até a galera
do consórcio ronda viu cabeça aqui
entrou em contato comigo e pediu para eu
contar essa história pra você ea
importância de se planejar as coisas
acontecerem o pai fez empréstimo e ter
que pagar o empréstimo
falando no interior e na garupa com ele
no carro para pedir comida nas casas que
a gente ia vender remédio novamente meu
pai olhar pra mim fazer sim ao índice
bom aí até 6 fim em mim eu estava com
fome
primeiro meu pai rolando eu e minha mãe
fez o consórcio da rodada tirou a moto
no instante meu pai ter não pagar a
modelista não pagar o empréstimo e
conseguir um emprego porque tinha uma
mota minha mãe é capaz de fazer o
consórcio já tinha conseguir conseguiu
também preso junto com meu pai nem
emprego deu tudo certo e deu tudo certo
olha como ambiental hoje graças a deus
deu tudo certo a este respeito anos
teria dado certo bem mais tranqüilo por
isso que é bom se planejar sem viver
muito mais tranqüilo e minha mulher nos
planejando para ter um filho daqui 1 10
15 anos mas até lá a gente vai viajar
esse mundo sem ter preocupação nenhuma
em toda festa que deve atrair vivo no
bbb tudo que der para beber dormir
nossas oito horas de sono tranquilo que
a gente não tem preocupação nenhum fazer
o que quiser chegar em casa às 6 horas
da manhã de amanhã recebendo depois de
comer aquele belo maravilhoso cachorro
quente da cidadania que fica na frente
da festa fazer tudo o que deve
eles e me preocupar com ninguém no dia
que meu filho fizer a mesma coisa vou
estar sentado na sala de manhã às 16
horas vendo ele abre a porta dizendo
bonito bonito né dito acho bonito em se
divertir
eu acho bonito chega em casa breve meia
da manhã que eu acho que é isso que o
álbum de ser pai você fazer tudo o que
quiser fazer na telha quando seus filhos
faziam sem dizer que não é pra fazer que
é perigo então obrigado pai por tudo que
o senhor fez pela gente muito obrigado
mundo por este convite de falar tá e
você quer sua moto o consórcio é o
melhor jeito de se planejar para
conseguir sua moto roda até aqui ó
dado seu trabalho com dados são mais de
35 mil contemplados por mês mais de 5
milhões de motos zero-quilômetro
entregues as parcelas acessíveis ea
tradição de um administrador de mais de
35 anos de meca aí que propagandeia
podia fazer na televisão é propagar o
universo da gucci ronda é a forma mais
inteligente de você planejar a conquista
da sua moto ondas são mais de 35 mil
contemplados todo mês sai de 5 milhões
de motos zero-quilômetro entregues com
parcelas acessíveis e uma administração
de mais de 35 anos eu só três
muito obrigado você assistir esse vídeo
o pai eu te amo obrigado por tudo que
você fez pela nossa família eu sei que
não foi nada fácil mas hoje graças a
deus a gente está colhendo frutos valeu
a pena eu to anunciou a vida que se eu
sempre quis vou trabalhar muito duro
para poder seguir seu exemplo e já
deixar o que tá bom muito melhor viu amo
você
obrigado não sei quando vai intervir
nesse canal então já vou desejar agora
feliz dia dos pais tamo junto
obrigado ronda e nós e eu sei que
ficando doido agora no começo eu o vi
fórum da esplanada vetar defende de paz
se você não tivesse vídeos não gostei em
que você come aqui embaixo coisas que
você acha que tá diferente de quando
você tinha 8 anos pra hoje muito
obrigado é nóis valeu e branca